IAN LAKE: If you've implemented
a get content activity
so other apps could access
files or photos from your app,
your life got a lot
easier in KitKat.
Rather than having to
implement your own activity,
build a whole U/I, and deal
with options like multi-select,
you can rely on the
Storage Access Framework
and build a DocumentsProvider.
A quick refresher on the
Storage Access Framework.
On KitKat and
higher devices, when
apps start a get
content intent, they'll
first get a system-provided U/I,
courtesy of the Storage Access
Framework.
This U/I automatically
connects to each app
that provides a
DocumentsProvider
and gives users
a consistent look
and feel and functionality
across all those apps.
Think of it as the open dialog
from a traditional operating
system.
Only at the end of
that list of apps
does any app use a
get content activity.
These document providers
are like the data backends
for your app.
With no U/I component,
it's completely
focused on returning a list
of files and some meta data
to make available to
the user to select right
there in the
system-provided U/I,
even allowing users
to select files
from multiple DocumentsProviders
at the same time.
There's only four required
methods for implementing
DocumentsProvider--
queryRoots(),
queryChildDocuments(),
queryDocument(),
and openDocument().
A root is the entry point
to your DocumentsProvider,
so queryRoots() is where
you'd return metadata,
like a unique root ID; the
title and icon for your root
for display to the user; an
optional summary for maybe
an account name; as well as
flags for enabling optional
functionality, such as returning
recent items, searching,
or creating new files.
It also includes a document
ID for the topmost directory.
It turns out when
we say "document,"
it can mean two different
things-- a traditional file--
something the user can open--
and a directory, a folder which
can contain other documents.
queryChildDocuments()
is where you're given
a directory's document ID, and
you return metadata about all
of its direct children
of that directory.
This metadata would include
document IDs; a display name--
what gets shown to the
user-- a MIME type,
and flags indicating whether
it could be written, deleted,
renamed, and more.
You might already be guessing
what queryDocument() does then.
It provides the same metadata,
just about a single document.
It's important to note that
while each document ID must
be unique, the same
document can appear
in different directories, say
if you categorize pictures
by both tags and date.
Then, of course, you do
actually need to provide
the document's contents, and
that's what openDocument()
does.
Now, it seems easy enough.
Yet when you look
at the actual API,
you note that many of these
methods return a cursor.
And many have a
projection as a parameter.
For those not working
on databases all day,
a cursor is just an interface
for iterating over rows of data
with each row having
a set of columns.
The projection that's
passed in indicates
what columns are being
requested by the Storage Access
Framework.
And your resulting
cursor should have a row
for each root or document.
If you don't have a database,
that's totally fine.
You can construct a cursor
manually using a matrix cursor.
You create one by passing in
the projection you want to use.
You'll note that a null
projection parameter means
you decide what
fields to return,
although there are some required
ones for DocumentsProviders,
so look through the links in
the description for the details.
Then for each row you want, you
first create it using newRow,
then call add.
For queryRoots(), use the
constants in the Documents
Contract Root class as the
keys for each piece of data.
And queryChildDocuments() and
queryDocuments() aren't much
different, although in that
case you'd use the Documents
Contract Document Class
for the constants.
Now, for openDocument, you're
tasked to return a parcel file
descriptor.
Thankfully, if you
already have a local file,
this is really straightforward.
Thanks to ParcelFileDescriptor's
Open method.
You can also create a
ParcelFileDescriptor directly
from a socket though, so
having the full local file
locally isn't a
hard requirement.
Of course, the
best implementation
won't do any good unless you
add your DocumentsProvider
to your Android manifest.
A couple things of note here.
You need a unique authority
for your DocumentsProvider,
generally something prefaced
with your application ID,
your package name.
Then you'll need to make
sure that it's exported,
so the Storage Access
Framework can access it,
grant-uri-permissions mean the
system can grant permissions
on your behalf,
and the permission
ensures only the Storage
Access Framework can connect
to your DocumentsProvider.
Now, that's it for the basics.
You should be able to see
your root and documents when
apps invoke the standard
documents U/I via get content,
or that
ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT intent.
No more need to
build your own U/I,
and a consistent experience,
whether users are operating
on local files or
files you provide
or files from some other app.
But this is really only the
beginning of the Storage Access
Framework.
There are optimizations for
loading huge lists of document,
with EXTRA_LOADING;
ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT_TREE,
for letting users select
whole directories to share;
ACTION_CREATE_DOCUMENT,
for saving a file, not
just locally, but to
any DocumentsProvider;
providing thumbnails;
document management
features like Deleting,
Renaming, Copying, Moving,
and Removing; alternate file
formats; and virtual files.
You'll find all the details in
the links in the description
and how you can use
the Storage Access
Framework to build a great
DocumentsProvider to build
better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]